has this ever happened to you stuck
watching annoying infomercials that show
people fumbling with products in black
and white and does it bring you down
when they reveal the solution by star
wiping to color mhm and do you cringe
when you hear the phrase there's got to
be a better way there's got to be a
better way to get rid of infomercial
there is you'll never have to watch paid
advertisements for Corner cutting
products again because the patented
infomercial stopper can get rid of
infomercials forever that sounds great
do you want a special gift of course
that's what infomercials say to hook you
in the infomercial stopper will get rid
of those extraneous gift offers forever
more plus you get a gift great the
infomercial stopper changed my life
thanks infomercial stopper are you sick
of clearly paid actors selling useless
products the infomercial stopper is
great it got rid of all those
infomercials that use clearly fake
testimonials take it for me I'm not an
actor but wait there's more really no oh
yes yes no yes yes with the infomercial
stopper you'll never be enticed by
needless add-ons again yes no oh don't
be fooled by imitations that say they'll
get rid of infomercials but don't
deliver the infomercial stopper is the
only one that can rid your life of
infomercials guaranteed for only three
easy payments of $19.95 plus shipping
and handling you'll never hear the words
plus shipping and handling only $19.95
or three easy payments ever again just
call 1 1800 stop longer than 7-digit
phone number 6
today